you
okay let's get started
so welcome to eighteen to seventeen so
this is combinatorial theory graph
theory and additive combinatorics so the
course website is up there so all the
course information is and there so after
around the middle of the class I'll say
a bit more about various course
information I mean the straight of
things but I want to jump directly into
the mathematical content so this course
roughly has two parts the first part
we'll look at graph theory in particular
expose an extremal graph theory and the
second part will transition to additive
combinatorics but these are not two
separate subjects so I want to show you
this topic in a way that connects these
two areas and show you that they are
quite related to each other and many of
the common themes that will come up in
one part of the course will also show up
in the other so the story between graph
theory and additive combinatorics began
about 100 years ago with sure a famous
mathematician Isaac sure well he was
like many mathematicians of his era
trying to prove Fermat's Last Theorem so
here's what's sure so approach I said
well let's look at this equation that
comes up in from our slash theorem and
well one of the methods of elementary
number theory to rule out solutions to
an equation is to consider what happens
when you mop it if you can rule out for
infinitely many values P possible
non-trivial solutions to this equation
mark P then you rule out possibilities
of solutions to Fermat's Last Theorem
okay so this was sure its approach as
you can guess unfortunately this
approach did not work and sure proved
that this method definitely doesn't work
so that's the starting point of our
discussion so it turns out
that for every value of n there exists
non-trivial solutions for all P
sufficiently large thereby ruling out
the strategy so let's see how sure
proved his theorem so that will be the
first half of today's lecture ok so this
seems like a number theory question so
what does it have to do with graph
theory so I want to show you this
connection now sure deduced his theorem
from another result that is known as
shirt's theorem which says that if the
positive integers is colored using
finitely many colors then there exists a
monochromatic solution to the equation X
plus y equals to Z if you give me 10
colors and color the positive integers
between those 10 colors then I can find
for you a solution to this equation
where x y and z are all of the same
color now this statement ok so it's a
perfectly understandable statement but
let me rephrase it in a somewhat
different way and this gets to a point
that I want to discuss where many
statements in additive combinatorics or
just combinatorics in general have
different formulations one that comes in
an infinite Airy form which is more
qualitative so to speak and another form
that is known as finite Airy
and that's more quantitative in nature
so shirt's theorem is stated in a
infinite hairy form so it tells you if
you color using finally many colors then
there exists a monochromatic solution so
many but not all statements of that form
have an equivalent finitary form that is
sometimes more useful and also once you
state the right finite reform you can
ask additional questions so here's what
shirts theorem looks like in the
equivalent finite hairy form you give me
an R for every art there exists some and
function of R such that if the numbers 1
through n so throughout this course I'm
going to use this bracket n to denote
integers up to n so if these numbers are
colored using our colors then
necessarily there exists a monochromatic
solution to the equation X plus y equals
to Z where XY and z are in the set that
is being colored so it looks very
similar to the first person I stated but
now there are some more quantifiers so
for every art there exists in n so why
are these two versions equivalent to
each other so it's not too hard to
deduce they're equivalent
so let me do that now
the fact that the finite area version
implies the infinity reversion claim
should be fairly obvious right so once
you know the finite area version if you
give me a coloring of the positive
integers or I just have to look far
enough up to this end and I get the
conclusion I want but now in the other
direction okay so in the other direction
suppose I fix you this R so okay so I
assume the infinite hairy version I want
it reduced the finite area version so I
start with this R and let's suppose the
conclusion were false okay so I'm
supposed to conclusion we're false
namely for every and there exists some
coloring okay so for every n there
exists some coloring which we will call
V sub n that avoids monochromatic
solutions to X plus y equals to C okay
so I'm gonna use this Chi for a
shorthand for monochromatic okay so
suppose there exists such a coloring and
now I want to take this collection of
colorings and produce for you a coloring
of the positive integers and you can do
this basically by a standard
diagonalization trick namely we see that
by taking a infinite subsequence
such that okay so let me call this
infinite subsequence fee of FISA it's an
infinite subsequence of this V sub n
such that V sub n of K stabilizes along
the subsequence for every K then okay so
you can do this simply by diagonals
agent Rick and then you see that along
the subsequence BN converges point-wise
to some coloring of the entire set of
positive integers and this coloring
avoid monochromatic solutions to X plus
y equals the deep because if there were
monochromatic solutions in this coloring
of the entire integers then I can look
back to you you know where that came
from and that would be in the
monochromatic solution in one of my fans
so this is an argument that shows the
equivalence between the finite area from
an infinite area form but now when we
look at the finite reform you can ask
additional questions such as how big
does this n have to be as a function of
R it turns out those kind of questions
in general are very difficult
and we know some things you know for
this type of questions we know some
bounds usually but the truth is usually
unknown and there are major open
problems in combinatorics of this type
all right so there's still a lot that we
do not understand okay so now we have
search term in this form let me show you
how to deduce his conclusion about
ruling out this approach to proving
Fermat's Last Theorem
all right so the claim is the following
that if you have a positive integer and
then for all sufficiently large Prime's
P there exists x y&z all belonging to
numbers integers up to P minus 1 such
that their nth powers add up like this
so it's a solution to Fermat equation
mod P all right so how can we deduce
this from what we said about coloring so
what is the coloring ok so here's what
sure do
so proof assuming for now sure stare so
let's look at the multiplicative group
of nonzero residue smartp so this is a
so we know it's a cyclic group because
there's a generator so there's a
primitive root generator let H denote
the subgroup of nth powers ok well
age is a pretty big subgroup okay so
what's the index of age in this
multiplicative group it's the most M so
think about representing this as a
cyclic group using a generator so H then
would be all the elements whose exponent
is divisible by M so this is the index
is at most M could be smaller but it's
at most M and so in particular I can use
the H cosets to partition the
multiplicative group of nonzero residues
and this is a color reversal partition
is the same thing as a coloring you know
there's a bounded number of colors but I
let peek at large so by shirts theorem
if P sufficiently large then one of my
cassettes should contain a solution to X
plus y equals to Z what does that look
like one Cosette Cosette contains X Y Z
such that X plus y equals to Z as
integers they belong to the same Cosette
so x y&z belong to some co set of H
which means then that x equals to a
times some and power with y equals to a
times some nth power and roti equals to
a times some power oh you have this
equation put them together so that is
true so now mod p I can cancel the ACE
and this produces a non trivial solution
to Fermat's equation motley ok so this
was the proof of this claim that this
method does not work for solving
Fermat's Last Theorem but you know we
assumed this claim a shirts theorem that
every finite coloring of the positive
integers contains a monochromatic
solution to X plus y equals to Z so we
still need to prove that claim right so
we still need to prove this
combinatorial claim and so that's what
we're gonna do now
this is where graph theory comes in so
let me state a very similar-looking
theorem about graphs and this is known
as Ramsey's theorem
although Ramsey Sturm actually
historically came after search term but
Ramsey's theorem here we're going to use
it specifically in the case for
triangles so what does I say that if you
give me an R the number of colors then
there exists some large n such that if
the edges of the complete graph K sub n
o n vertices are colored using our
colors then there exists a monochromatic
triangle somewhere
okay any questions so far about any of
these statements so let's see how
Ramsey's theorem for triangles is proved
by the way I want to give you a
historical note about Frank Ramsey so if
someone who made significant
contributions to many different areas
not just in mathematics so he
contributed to a seminal works in
mathematical logic where this theorem
came from but also to philosophy and to
economics before his untimely death at
the age of 26 from liver related
problems so someone who very it's very
short life contributed tremendously to
academics okay so let's see how Ramsey's
theorem in this case is true
what do induction are the number of
colors so for every R I need to show you
some n such that the statement is true
in the first case when R equals to 1
there's not much to do just one color if
I just have three vertices that already
it's okay three vertices it's already a
monochromatic triangle so from now on
let R be at least 2 and suppose the
claim holds for R minus 1 colors with M
prime being the corresponding number of
vertices with R minus 1 colors so now
let me pick an arbitrary vertex so pick
an arbitrary vertex B and look what
happens so here's V and let me look at
the outgoing edges so because ok so let
me show that ok so what show that and
being R times M prime minus
plus two works so now we have a lot of
outgoing edges in particular we have our
times M prime minus 1 plus 1 outgoing
edges so by the pigeonhole principle
some color so so there exists at least M
Prime
outgoing edges with the same color let's
say yellow
so suppose yellow is the outgoing color
and let me call the set of vertices on
the other end of these edges B naught
okay so now let's think about what
happens in be not so in V not either V
naught contains a yellow edge in which
case you get a yellow triangle
or we lose the color inside v-not so the
number of colors goes down else has at
most R minus 1 colors and V naught has
at least M prime number vertices so by
induction V naught has a monochromatic
triangle in the remaining colors ok so
that completes the proof of rameses
theorem in this case for triangles and
you can if you wish to find out you know
what is the bound that comes out of this
argument well you can chase the proof
and get some doubt the remaining
question now is what does this all have
to do were sure Sturmer so so far we
talked about some number theory we've
talked about some graph theory and how
to link these two things together and I
think this is a great example it's a
fairly simple example which I'm about to
show you of how to link these two ideas
together and this connection will see
many times in the rest of this course
[Applause]
don't want a race sure sir what so
that's true theorem so let's start with
a covering so let's start with the
coloring of one through n and now I want
to form a graph with colors on the edges
there are somehow derived from this
coloring on these integers and here's
what I'm going to do so let's color the
complete graph to color the edges of the
complete graph the vertex set having n
plus 1 vertices label that integers up
to positive integers up to n plus 1
oh by the Remzi result we just proved if
n is large enough
then there exists a monochromatic
triangle so what does it look like so
here's so let me draw you draw for you a
monochromatic triangle suppose it so I
haven't told you what the coloring is
yet so the coloring is that I'm going to
color the edge between inj using the
color derived by applying fee to the
number J minus I namely the length of
that segment if I lay out all the
vertices on the number line so now I
have our coloring of this complete graph
so Ramsey tells us that there exists a
monochromatic triangle the triangle sits
on vertices I J and K and the rule tells
us that the colors are fee of K - I see
of J minus I and fee of K minus J okay
so these three numbers they have the
same coloring but look if I set these
numbers to be XY and Z so X being J
minus I for instance then X plus y
equals to Z and they all have the same
color so this monochromatic triangle
gives us a monochromatic equation 2x
plus y equals to Z thereby concluding
the proof of shirts theorem okay so this
rounds out the discussion for now of
well we started with some statement
about number theory
and then we took this detour to graph
theory looking at Ramsey's terms
monochromatic triangles and then got
back to number theory and proved the
result that sure did so how does go into
graphs help so why was this advantageous
what do you guys think sorry I claimed
that by going to graphs we added some
extra flexibility to what we can play
with for example we started out with a
problem where there were only n things
being colored and then we moved to
graphs where about and schuster and
squared objects are being colored and
then we did an induction argument so
remember in the proof of rameses theorem
up there there was an induction argument
taking out vertices and that argument
doesn't make that much sense if you
stayed within the numbers somehow moving
to grass gave you that extra flexibility
allow you to do more things and this is
one of the advantages of moving from
from about numbers to a problem about
graphs and we'll see this connection
later on as well
right so so Ashwin asked are there so
what about bounce can you so what do we
know about bounce so I don't know off
the top of my head the answers to those
questions but in general they're quite
open so they're exponential gaps between
lower and upper bounds on our knowledge
of what is the optimal and you can put
in the theorem any more questions all
right so I think this is a good point
for us too so usually when I give
90-minute lectures I like to take a
short two-minute break in between so so
I won't do that and then in the second
half I want you take you through a tour
of additive combinatorics so tell you
about some of the modern developments
now this is an exciting field where you
know it started out I think roughly
worth sure Sturm that we just discussed
that started about 100 years ago but a
lot has taken place in the past century
and there still a lot of ongoing
exciting research developments so in the
second half of this lecture I want to
give you a tour through those
developments and show you some of the
highlights from additive combinatorics
okay so let's take a quick two minute
break and feel free to you know ask
questions so another part of the writing
assignment in addition to course notes
is a contribution to Wikipedia which is
you know nowadays of course you know if
you hear some word like similarities
regularity lemma the first thing you do
is type into Google and more often than
not the first link that comes up is
Wikipedia and you know some of the
articles there are alright and some of
them are really not alright and it would
be fantastic you know for future
students and also for yourselves if
there were you know better entry points
to this area by having higher quality
Wikipedia articles or articles that are
simply missing about specific topics so
one of the assignments again this can be
collaborative so I'll give you more
information how to do that later
to contribute to Wikipedia and roughly
you contribute one high quality article
or edit some existing articles so that
they become high-quality yep so we can
talk about that yeah so if there are
other ideas about you know how to do
this we can definitely open the chatting
about that so the other thing is that
instead of holding the usual office
hours what I like to do is okay so this
class ends at 4:00 p.m. so after 4:00
I'll go up to the math common room which
is just right upstairs
I'm hanging out there for a bit if you
have questions you want to chat come
talk to me I'd be happy to chat about
anything related or not related to the
course and before homeworks are due I
will try to set up some special office
hours for you to you know in case you
wanna ask about homework proms and if
you want to meet with me individually
please just send me an email or one more
thing about the course notes or so
because you know I want you do quality
control so here's the process that will
happen with the course notes so the
first lecture is already online so you
can already see so I've written up the
lecture notes for the first lecture and
you can use that as an example of what
I'm looking for so I'm looking for
people to sign up starting from the next
lecture and I will send out a link
tonight for future lectures so whoever
writes that lecture oh right the lecture
and then within one day so by the end of
the day after the lecture will be good
if they were already only some sketch
some rough draft you know at least
containing a theorem statements and
whatnot from today's lecture so that the
next person can start writing afterwards
but once you are done once you feel that
you have a polished version of the
lecture write-up ideally within four
days of the lecture right so that's
terms of expectations and timelines
again all of this information is online
so you're finished with polishing your
lecture notes within four days send me
an email
so both co-authors if there are two of
you and I will schedule a appointment
about half an hour's
well I will sit down with you to go
through what you've written and tell you
some comments so you can go back and you
know polish it further and hopefully
that will just be a one round thing if
it more rounds are needed well it's not
ideal but you know what make it happen
until the notes are ready to use for
future generations okay any questions
about any of the course logistics
alright so in the second half of today's
lecture I want to take you through a
tour of modern additive combinatorics
and this is an area of research which I
am actively involved in and it's
something that I'm quite excited about
and part of the reason why I teach this
courses or this course is something that
I developed a couple years ago when I
talked for the first time then because I
want to introduce you guys to this very
active and exciting area of research now
what is additive combinatorics it's the
term itself is actually fairly new so
the word the term additive combinatorics
I believe was coined by Terry towel back
in the early 2000s as somewhat of a
rebranding of area that already existed
but then got a lot of exciting
developments in the early 2000s it's a
deep and far-reaching subject with many
connections to areas like graph theory
harmonic analysis or Fourier analysis or
Gothic theory discrete geometry logic
and model theory and has many
connections all over the place and also
has many deep theorems so let me take
you through a tour historically of I
think some of the major milestones and
landmarks in additive combinatorics
so after shirt's theorem which do we
discuss in the first half of today's
lecture the next big result I would say
is mandolins theorem which was 1927
bender Worden's theorem says that every
coloring
the positive integers using finitely
many colors contains arbitrarily long
our thematic progressions so well see
our to make progressions come up a lot
so from now on we'll abbreviate this
word by a P a P stands for arithmetic
progressions so instead of shirts term
where you just find a single solution 2x
plus y equals to Z so now we're finding
a much bigger structure now keep in mind
so a novice mistake is people make is to
confuse arbitrarily long arithmetic
progressions with infinitely long so
these are definitely not the same so you
can think about I'll leave it to you as
an exercise that's also homework
exercise that you can color the integers
with just two colors in a way that
destroys all possible infinitely long
monochromatic bharatham dick
progressions so arbitrarily long is very
different from infinitely long no so
this was you know it's a great result
but it provokes small questions so
erudition Tarang in the 30s they asked
well they conjectured that the true
reason in vendor wardens theorem of
having wrong arithmetic progressions
it's not so much that you're coloring
it's just because if you use finitely
many colors than one of the color
classes must have fairly high density so
one of the classes use our colors has
density at least one over R and they
conjectured that every subset
of the positive integers or the integers
with positive density contains long so
arbitrarily long arithmetic progressions
you may ask what is the mean density so
you can define density in many different
ways and it doesn't actually really
matter that much which definition you
use but let me write down one definition
so you can define given a subset of
integers the upper density rather let me
just say that it has positive
opportunity if when we take the limbs
soup as and goes to infinity and look at
we'll take a scaling window and look at
what fraction of that window is a that
this number this limit soup is positive
so that's one definition of positive
density there are many other definitions
sometimes known as no Pollock density
you can take variations but they're all
I mean for the purpose of this
discussion they're all roughly
equivalent so let's not worry too much
about which definition of density we use
here all right so erudition Terron
conjectured that the true reason for
bend awareness term is that one of the
color classes has positive density and
this turned out to be in an amazingly
impressive question and that one had to
wait several decades so this conjecture
was made in the 30s 1936 so you have to
wait several decades before finding out
what the answer is so in a foundational
theorem in the subject namasthe Roth's
theorem
so Roth proved it in the 50s I think 50
in the 50s that K equals to 3 it's true
so if I say that it contains K term
arithmetic progressions for every K and
Roth proved that every positive density
subset contains a three term arithmetic
progressions and already you know Roth
introduced very important ideas that we
will see in this course in two different
forms so in the first half the course
will see a graph theoretic proof that
was found later in the 70s of Ross
theorem and then in the second half
we'll see Roth's original proof that
used Fourier analysis so Fourier
analysis in number theory is also known
as the hardy Littlewood circle method
it's a powerful method analytic number
theory but they are very interesting new
ideas introduced by Roth as well in
developing this result the full
conjecture was settled by summer Eddie
it took another couple of decades late
70s SEM already proved his landmark
theorem that confirmed the air - Terron
conjecture similarly Sturm is a deep
theorem this theorem is the proof to
what the original combinatorial proof is
a tour de force and you can look at the
introduction of his paper where there's
an enormous Li complex diagram ok so you
can see this in the course notes that
they saw the logical dependencies of the
all dilemmas and propositions in Kim's
paper and even if you assume every
single statement is true looking at that
diagram it's not immediately clear what
is going on because the logical
dependencies are so involved
so this is you know this was a really
complex proof and but not only that
similarly Sturm actually motivated a lot
of subsequent research so later on
researchers from other areas came in and
found also sophisticated proofs of
similarities theorem from other areas
and using other tools including and here
are some of the most important
perspectives later perspectives of
summer and Easter so they were say proof
using our Gothic theory that followed
fairly shortly after similarities or to
no proof this is due to Furstenberg and
initially it wasn't clear because all of
these proofs were so involved it wasn't
clear if the ergodic the red-eye proof
was genuinely something new or it was a
rephrasing of similarities combinatorial
proof but then very quickly it was
realized that there were extensions of
similarities theorem other combinatorial
results that the ergodic theorists could
establish using their methods using the
same methods or extensions of the same
methods that combinatorial as' did not
know how to do and to this date there
are still theorems from which the only
known proofs use organic theory I
suppose extensions of similarity system
and I will mention one later on today so
that's one of the perspectives the other
perspective that was also quite
influential is something known as
higher-order Fourier analysis which was
pioneered by and Gower's in around 2000
so Gower's won Fields Medal party for
his work on Banach spaces but also party
for for this development so higher-order
Fourier analysis is in some sense an
extension of Roth's
theorem so by the way Roth also won
Fields Medal although this is not his
most famous there I'll say it's second
most famous there so Roth used this
Fourier analysis in the sense of hardly
a middle would to control three term
arithmetic progressions but it turns out
that that method for very good
fundamental reasons completely fails for
for time arithmetic progressions yes oh
well see later in the course why why
that's the case why is it that you
cannot do Fourier analysis to control
for turn a piece but Gower's managed to
find a way to overcome that difficulty
and he came up with an extension with a
generalization of Fourier analysis very
powerful very difficult to use actually
but that allows you to understand high
longer arithmetic progressions another
very influential approach is called
hyper graph regularity
so the hyper graph regularity method was
also discovered in the early 2000s
independently by team led by Rhodope and
also back hours so hyper graph
regularity method it's an extension of
what's known as Emiratis regularity
similarly this graph regularity method
and this is the method that will be a
central topic in the first half of this
course and it's a method that is quite
central all these some of the ideas
quite central to similarities method and
he gave an alternative proof he and
rochelle gave an alternative proof of
gloucester using graph theory and for a
long time people realized that one could
extend some of those ideas to hyper
graphs but working out how that proof
goes actually took an enormous amount of
time and effort and resulted in this
amazing theorem on hyper graph I mean
mention these are not the only methods
that were used to extend summaries
theorem we'll get the alternate proofs
there are many others for example you
may have heard of something called the
polymath project
raise your hand if you heard of the
polymath project okay great so so maybe
about half of you so this is a online
collaborative project started by Tim
Gower's and and also famous people like
Terry tell and they were all quite
involved in various polymath projects
and the first successful polymath
project produced a combinatorial proof
of something known as the density Hales
duet theorem so I won't explain well if
this year so it's something which is
related to take that whole but so it's
so it's a deep combinatorial theorem
that happy known earlier using or Gothic
theoretic methods but they gave a new
combinatorial proof in particular gave
some concrete bounds on this theorem and
that in particular also implies some
reddish theorem so this gave a new proof
and as a result they online
collaborative project so they published
this paper under the pseudonym dhj
polymath where d HJ s that stands for
density he'll Stewart and they kept the
same name for all of the subsequent
papers published by the polymath project
so as you see you know through all of
these examples that there were a lot of
work that were motivated by some are
disturbed this is truly a foundational
result of foundational theorem that you
know gave way to a lot of you know
important research and similarly himself
received an apple price for his seminal
contributions to combinatorics and also
theoretical computer science
we still don't understand in some sense
completely what's Emiratis theorem you
know what for example we don't
understand
the optimal bounds and also more
importantly conceptually we don't really
understand how these methods are related
to each other
so there's some vague sense that they
all have some common themes but it's
still you know there's a lot of mystery
as to what do these methods coming from
very different areas organic Theory
harmonic analysis graph theory what do
they all have to do with each other
but there's one central theme and this
is also going to be a theme in this
course which is goes under the name and
I believe Terry towel is the one who
popularized this name the dichotomy
between structure and randomness
structure and pseudo randomness somehow
is a really fancy way of saying signal
versus noise so I give you some object
give you some complex object and there
is some mathematical way to separate the
structure from some noisy aspects which
behave random like so there are be many
places in this course where this
dichotomy will play an important role
any questions at this point
I want to take you through some
generalizations and extensions of
samurai DS theorem so first let's look
at what happens if we go to higher
dimensions suppose we have a subset in D
dimensions D dimensional lattice so we
can also define some notion of density
again it doesn't matter precisely what
is the notion you use for example we can
say that has positive opportunity okay
so similarly this term in one dimensions
tells us that if you have some set of
positive density that I can find
arbitrarily long arithmetic progressions
so what should the corresponding
generalization in higher dimensions
here's a notion I can define namely that
we say a contains arbitrary
constellations
to mean that so what else I mean so
constellation you can think of it as
some finite pattern so a set of stars in
the sky so some pattern and I want to
find that pattern somewhere in a where
I'm allowed to dilate allowed you to
multiply pattern by some number and also
translate ok so I want to find this
pattern so what I mean precisely is that
for every finite subset of the grid
there exists some translation and some
dilation such that once I apply this
translation dilation and translation to
my pattern F okay meaning and looking at
the image of this F under this
transformation then this set lies inside
a see that are automatic progressions is
the constellation just numbers 1 through
K ok so that's a definition and the
multi-dimensional same ready theorem so
the multi-dimensional generalization of
similarities theorem says that for every
subset so every subset of the D
dimensional lattice of positive density
contains arbitrary constellations
you give me a pattern and I can find
this pattern inside a provided that a
has positive density so in particular if
I want to find a 10 by 10 square grid so
meaning suppose I want to find a pattern
which consists of something like that a
10 by 10 square grid where all of these
lengths are equal but I don't specify
what they are but as long as they're
equal then the dirham tells me that as
long as a has positive density then I
can find such a pattern inside a so so
this theorem was proved by Furstenberg
and cuts Nelson so you see that it is a
generalization of Samaras term or so the
one-dimensional case is precisely
Sammarinese theorem so first time Bergen
cuts Nelson using a gothic theory showed
that one can generalize somewhere this
term to the multi-dimensional setting
however the combinatorial approaches
employed by similarity did not easily
generalize so it took another couple of
decades at least for people to find a
combinatorial proof of this result and
namely that happened with the hyper
graph regularity method so this was one
of the motivations of this of this
project and you say ok what's the point
of having different proofs well one
thing it's nice to know you know
different perspectives on two important
there but there's also no concrete
objective in particular it turns out
that if you prove something using or
gothic theory because ok so we will not
discuss a conic theory in this course
but roughly you know one of the early
steps in
proof applies compactness and that
already destroys any chance of getting
concrete quantitative bounce so you can
ask if I want to find a ten by time
pattern and I have density one percent
how large do I need to look how far do I
have to look in order to find that
patter so that's a quantitative question
that is actually not at all addressed by
organic theory so in later methods using
combinatorial methods give you concrete
bounds so there are some concrete
differences between these methods so
this theorem reminds me of this scene
from the movie A Beautiful Mind just
greatest mathematical movies some sense
and so there's a scene in there where
Russell Crowe you know playing John Nash
know so they were at this fancy party
and Nash was with his soon-to-be wife
Alicia and he points to the sky and
tells her and pick a shape pick a shape
and I can find for you among the stars
and so this is what the theorem allows
you to do right so if you have so give
me a shape and I can find that
constellation inside a let's look at
other generalizations so far we are
looking at linear patterns so looking at
linear dilations and translations but
what about polynomial patterns so here's
a question suppose I give you a dense
subset of positive density subset of
integers can you find two numbers whose
difference is a perfect square so this
question was asked by lavas and a
positive answer was given in the late
70s by Furstenberg
first time Birkin jacuzzi
they showed using different methods one
regarding theoretic and the other is
more harmonic analytic that every subset
of the integers subset of positive
integers with positive density contains
two numbers differing by a perfect
square so in other words we can always
find the pattern X X plus y squared so
what about other polynomial patterns
instead of this Y squared suppose you
just give me some other polynomial or
maybe a collection of polynomials so
what can I say well there are some
things for which this is not true okay
you give me an example where if I put in
a wrong polynomial it's not true well if
the polynomial is the constant one if
you take the even numbers as density 1/2
but it doesn't contain any patterns of X
and X plus one so so I need to say some
hypotheses about these polynomials so a
vast generalization of this result known
as the polynomial similarity theorem
says that if a is a subset of integers
with positive density
and if we have these polynomials P 1
through P K with integer coefficients
and 0 constant terms then I can always
find a pattern so there exists some X
and positive integer Y such that this
pattern X plus P 1 of Y X plus P 2 of Y
and so on X plus PK of why they all lie
in a so in other words succinctly every
subset of integers with cost intensity
contains arbitrary polynomial patterns
so this was proved so this was an
important result proved by Ferguson and
Lippmann using organic theory and so far
for this general statement the only
known proof uses or Gothic theory so
there were some recent developments
recent pretty exciting developments that
for some specific cases where if you
have some additional restrictions on the
piece then there are other methods
coming from for you and it is a harmonic
and analytic methods that could give you
different proof that allows you to get
some thanks remember organic de Veracruz
gives you no bounds but so far in
general the only method known is
regarding thematic and actually Ferguson
Liebman proved something which is more
general than what I have stated so
there's also true in a multi-dimensional
set I won't stay that precisely but you
can imagine what it is
let me mention one more theorem that
many of you imagine a photo and this is
the Green County room so the Green
County room says that the primes contain
arbitrarily long arithmetic progressions
so this is a famous theorem and it's one
of the most celebrated results of the
past couple of decades and resolved some
long-standing folklore conjectures in
number theory the Green kalkaryn you see
that in informants look somewhat like
similarities theorem but it doesn't
follow from summer lease term what the
primes they don't have positive density
the prime number theorem tells us the
density the case like 1 over log n so
what about quantitative versions of
similarities term it is possible
although we do not know how to prove
such statement it is possible that a
density of primes along my guarantee the
green Cottenham
in that it is possible that similarities
theorem is true for any set whose
density the case like the prime numbers
like 1 over log n but that is no we're
quite far from proving such a statement
and that's not what green and how did
instead they took
Samaras theorem as a black box and
applied it to some variant of the primes
and showed that inside this variant
similarly this term is also true and
that the Prime's sit inside this variant
of the Prime's normal pseudo Prime's as
a set of relatively positive density of
somehow transferring Samaras theorem
from the dense setting to a sparse or
setting so this is a very exciting
technique and as a result Green Kyle
proved not just that the primes contain
a
virtually long or thematic progressions
but every relatively dense so relatively
past the density subset the primes
contains arbitrarily long arithmetic
progressions but to prove this theorem
they incorporated into many different
ideas coming from many different areas
of mathematics including harmonic
analysis you know some ideas coming from
combinatorics number theory as well so
there were some innovations at the time
in number theory that were employed in
this result so this is certainly a
landmark theorem and although we will
not discuss the full proof of the green
code theorem we will go into some of the
ideas throughout this course and I will
show you in a bit some pieces and that
we will see throughout the course okay
so this is a meant to be a very fast
tour of what happened in the last
hundred years in additive combinatorics
you're taking you from shirt's theorem
which was seen really about 100 years
ago to something that is much more
modern but now you know instead of being
up in the stars let's come back down to
earth and I want to talk about in the
world you next so what are some of the
things that we can actually proof that
doesn't involve you know taking up in 50
pages using a complex logical diagram as
some Renny did in his paper so what are
some of the simple things that we can
start with well so first let's go back
to Ross theorem all right so Ross
theorem we've stated it up there but let
me restate it in a finite area form the
roster ms the statement that every
subset of integers 1 through n that
avoids three term arithmetic
progressions
must have size gluto all of em so we
earlier we gave an infinite airy
statement that if you have a positive
density subset of the integers that
contains a 380 this is an equivalent
finitary statement Roth's original proof
used Fourier analysis and a different
proof was given in the 70s by Russia and
similarly using graph theoretic methods
so how this graph theory have to do with
this result and that shouldn't be
surprising to you at this point given
that we already saw how we used Ramsey's
theorem graph theoretic result to prove
shirt's theorem which is something that
is number theoretic so something similar
happens but now the question is what is
the graph theoretic problem that we need
to look at so for sure Sturm it was
Ramsey's theorem for triangles or what
about for Ross theorem and naive guess
is the following so what's the question
that we should ask here's a somewhat
naive guess which turns out not to be
the right question but still an
interesting question which is that what
is the maximum number of edges in a
triangle free graph vertices now this is
not totally a stupid guess because you
know as you imagine from what we said
with shirts theorem somehow you know you
want to set up a graph so that the
triangles correspond to the three-term
arithmetic progressions and you want to
set it up in such a way that this
question about you know what's the
maximum size subset of 1 through m
without three atps translates into some
questionable you know what's the maximum
number of edges in a graph that has some
property what is that property so this
is not a totally stupid
but turns out this question is
relatively easy so it has a name so this
was found by mental about 100 years ago
Noah's mint house theorem and the answer
well you all see a proof so the first
thing we'll do in the next lecture is
proof mint house term but you know I
don't want to hold suspense I mean the
answer turns out to be fairly simple to
describe namely that you split the
vertices into two basically equal halves
and you join all the possible edges
between the two so there's a complete
bipartite graph with two equal sized
parts and turns out this graph you see
this triangle free and they also turns
out have the maximum number of edges
yep question let me get to that in a
second okay so I'll talk about
asymptotics in a second
okay so turns out this is not the right
graph theoretic question to ask so what
is the right graph there better question
to ask
so it's I'll tell you what it is I mean
it it shouldn't be clear to you at this
point it still seems like an interesting
question but it's also somewhat bizarre
to think about if you never seen this
before so what is the maximum number of
edges in an N vertex graph where every
edge flies in exactly one triangle
so I won the graph with lots and lots of
edges where every edge sits in exactly
one triangle now you might have some
difficulty even coming up with good
graphs to have this property and that's
okay these are very strange things to
think about and but we'll see many
examples of it later on and we'll also
see how Ross theorem is connected to
this graph theoretic question I'm just
to give you a hint you know where does
exactly one triangle come from it's
because even if you avoid three-term
arithmetic progressions they are still
these trivial three-term arithmetic
progressions where you keep the same
number three times and in graph
theoretic world that comes to the unique
triangle there every edge sits out so to
address the question about quantitative
bounds for rough theorem it turns out
that you know we have upper bounds or
lower bounds and it is still a wide open
question as to you know what these
things should be and roughly speaking
the best lower bound comes from a
construction which we'll see later in
this course the highest size around n
divided by e to the C roots log N and
the best upper bound is of the form
roughly and over log n may be a little
bit hard to think about how these
numbers behave so if you raise both
sides to the denominator to eat the
something then it's maybe easier to
compare but it's still pretty far gap so
still pretty big gap there's a famous
conjecture of
air dish some of you might heard of that
if you have a subset of a positive
integers with divergent harmonic series
then it contains arbitrarily long or
thematic progressions that's a very
attractive statement but somehow I don't
like this statement so much because it
seems to make a tube
pretty and the statement really is about
what is the bounds on Ross theorem and
our Sammarinese theorem and having
divergent harmonic series is roughly the
same as trying to prove
Ross theorem slightly better than the
bound that we currently have somehow
breaking this logarithmic barrier so
that conjecture that having divergent
harmonic series implies three-term a
piece it's still open that is still
opens where the bounds very close to
what we can prove but it is still open
for this question we will see later in
this course
once we've developed similarities
regularity lemma that the we can prove
an upper bound of OTV and squared and
that will suffice for proving Ross there
turns out we don't know what the right
answer should be we don't know whether
it's the best such graph and turns out
the best construction for this graph
there comes from over here the best
lower bound construction of a set of a
large set without three term arithmetic
progressions all right so I'm giving you
a preview of more of these connections
between additive combinatorics on one
hand and graph theory on the other hand
that we'll see you know throughout this
course any questions ok so just to tell
you what's going to happen next so the
next thing that we're going to discuss
is basically extremal graph theory in
particular if you forbid some structure
so just a triangle maybe a four cycle
maybe some other graph what can you say
about the maximum number of edges and
there are still a lot of interesting
open problems even even for that I
forbid some H what's the maximum number
of edges alright so the next few
lectures will be on that topic